first on cbs mornings a classic
children's tv show from the 1980s is
getting a modern makeover here's a hint
[Music]
so reading rainbow is making a comeback
and hoping to reach a new generation of
kids after more than 15 years off the
air it's set to return early next year
as reading rainbow live an interactive
children's program with multiple hosts
from diverse backgrounds we spoke with
the show's creative director amy guliamo
and one of the new co-hosts rohit gopal
listen
now
those kids that grew up with reading
rainbow are parents and teachers like me
and we want to honor that and we're
grateful for
the legacy of reading rainbow but we
really want kids and viewers to see
themselves in this show even though it's
through a screen we can make them feel
like they're in the studio with us and
that's something that we're really
really all right so this is really cool
you know what what else they're gonna do
they're going to have a like i said a
rotating cast of hosts but they are
still looking for some more so
i did i raised my hand too i was like me
now you got nate there's other games no
i would love to i would love to
say no if they ask me you know what else
is cool amy's glasses yeah
but you know what i learned about it i
said i'd like to do it they go well send
us your tape i'm like i got to audition
like what's going on
this is the tape this is the thing
i'll send him this back exactly it
wouldn't hurt if you read a book or two
just so they see the inflection that you
do when you read it oh so gayle wants
you to audition too
[Laughter]
like rodney dangerfield you don't get it